sheriff Chris Fitzgerald of Barron
County Wisconsin led the search for
Jamie and the investigation into the
murder of her parents we spoke with Tara
Fitzgerald just a few minutes ago
sheriff Fitzgerald when I saw you last
night you were on your way over to the
class family home and you said you were
excited but you were a little nervous
yes they wasn't nervous because you know
just seeing Jamie for the first time and
and what we worked so hard for what this
community and what the whole nation has
worked hard for and what Jamie showed us
the will of her to survive in the world
to escape what can you tell us about
Jake Patterson because we've heard from
two very reliable sources that he has in
fact in fact confessed and that he is
speaking what can you tell us about that
yeah I can't comment on mr. Patterson at
all that's part of our active
investigation this case remains very
fluid and active at this time our source
is correct can you say that I can't
comment anything on mr. Patterson are
you pretty confident that there's no one
else involved in this case yes from what
I've been told by my team
both of FBI DCI State Patrol that he
acted alone and I want to know about you
personally you have a 13 year old and
you have a 16 year old that's correct
I mean you were you know most police
officers are just effects nothing but
the facts but we've seen such a human
side of you I remember at the first
press conference you said your knees
actually buckled what is this meant for
you personally this case it's taking its
toll it's been hard but there's been a
lot of extra hugs at home and it's been
nice but yeah it's emotional we're a
small town community we work together
and this community showed its support
for Jamie in this case and now Jamie
showed us now the world they're
survivors she's the hero there's no
question about it yeah I feel so too we
were so glad she's home and thank you so
much for taking the time you got a busy
day today thank you a lot of people
praising sheriff Fitzgerald they said
he's been stellar leading this
investigation he's well-liked here